The Django REST framework is a flexible toolkit for building web APIs using Python.
Bobby Stearman teaches this course about how to use the Django REST framework.
Bobby is a senior software engineer and has created many popular tutorials.
Hi everyone and welcome to this course that I'm putting together for free CodeCamp over the next
hour or so. I'll be showing you everything you need to know to build your own web API
using Django REST framework. I'm Bobby Stearman from DigCoding and welcome to this course.
Let's begin. Hi and welcome to the start of this course. So let's cover this off straight away.
What is Django REST framework? Well, it's a toolkit that allows you to build
web APIs. Okay, so think of it as a standalone API where your clients can make requests such as get,
post, put, delete requests to you. Your API receives this information, it validates the
information and it responds to the user. That's essentially what we're trying to do here. It's
very powerful. It's very popular. A lot of projects that I work on these days are using Django REST
framework. Some of the projects that I use or I work on at the minute just use Django REST
framework as a backend and then they use a react or review front end. So a single page application.
Like I said, it's very popular, very powerful. That's why I decided to put this course together.
It'll take me about an hour to an hour and a half to finish the course. It's made up of eight
modules. The first two modules are cloning down a repository that we've got on GitHub.
And then module three onwards will be looking at building models, serializers, routers and views.
Okay. By the end of this course, we will have a fully functional web API where we can make
requests to, and we will get responses. And in the background, it'll be saving information to a
database. Okay. Each module comes with a set of instructions, so step by step guides, and this can
all be found on GitHub, which I'll show you in a moment or two. I will be here following along
every single step of the way. Like I said, at the end of this course, we'll have an app that
hopefully you can then refactor and add it to your own project. Okay. So let's begin.
What you can see on screen is Django REST Framework's homepage. Now this is a great
reference point for their documentation. It's got examples. It shows you how to install stuff.
It's fantastic. If ever you hit a brick wall or a dead end, this is always a good place to start.
Always read the docs. So I'll be referencing this a few times throughout the course.
Another thing, Docker. This project is a Django project that's entirely Dockerized.
So it stands to reason that it's a good idea if you have Docker and Docker Compose installed on
your local machine. That way, when you clone everything down, you can follow along with me
every single step of the way. It just makes it a lot easier when putting a course like this together
and it negates the need for prerequisites like Python and curl or HTTP on your machine.
So by installing Docker, it allows you just to keep up and be a lot. It's a lot more fluid.
Okay. So pause the video, install Docker and come back.
Last link that I want to show you is GitHub. You do not need a GitHub account to get your
hands on this code. It's a public repository. If you don't have a GitHub account, click the
green button here, download zip, extract the files on your local machine and you've got the code.
Okay. So you don't need an account. However, if you do have an account,
you have some options of cloning this repository and I'll show you those in a second.
So the project is called drf underscore course. It has numerous different branches. Main is default.
That's just kind of the empty box. If you like hasn't got much is the very, very bare bones
of the project. You have a complete branch. That's the complete project. And if you clone that down,
you skip forward to the end of the course and you've got all of the code.
I would advise you to watch the video as it's a much better way of doing a deeper dive on drf.
Okay. And then you've got one module or one branch for each module. So there's eight modules in the
course module one and module two are set up configurations and module three onwards is building
out of the app. Okay. So these are the directories and the files, and then you've got a read me file.
Okay. So bit of an intro. So welcome to the course is great if you're looking to learn drf.
And it's also great if you're looking to build an API. Like I said, it's popular, it's powerful,
and it really will be a good string to your bow. It does say prerequisites of Python 3.10.
I do use matching case statements in this course, and only got released in Python 3.10. If you've
got it on your local machine, great. However, the containers in Docker already have Python 3.10 in
there, so you shouldn't really need them. Also, I go on to say that you it's handy to make calls to
the API to have curl or HTTP installed on your machines that you can make calls. But again,
I've got containers built in this project with it all loaded up. So you don't need to install
anything. So that's why I say install Docker. Okay, let's get started. When we clone this down,
we want to clone it down into a directory and you want the local machine called drf underscore
course. That is our root directory. I reference it a lot throughout the course. So please call it by
that name. Don't call it Bobby's course, Billy's course, call it drf underscore course. It just
makes our life a lot easier. I've already got one on my machine and my text editor, which in this
case is BS code is already open in that directory. Okay, so I've skipped that part. But if you can
open up this directory, and then take the clone code from here, I have an SSH key, you can use
this GitHub CLI if you have it or the HTTPS option. I have an SSH key. So I'll be using that.
And lastly, before I open up VS code. Each of these modules are recorded individually as well
on my own YouTube channel. So if you like this course, and you like this content, then I advise
having a look at the decoding channel and the playlist on there. Because like I say,
if you like this content, you probably like the other content that I put out there. So that's
that. I've copied over my git clone command, let's open up VS code. As you can see here,
let's make it a bit bigger. I've got drf course here. And it's a instance of my VS code. So new
terminal. Right click that in there, the little full stop at the end here will clone it down
into drf. I have a passphrase. So I'll pop that in there. And there we have it. Great. So what
I like about VS code is especially when you're coding in Python, and do Django apps, VS code
has a whole bunch of extensions that make it act like an ID. And it's very, very good when you're
using Python. So I would strongly advise that you get it installed in your machine if you're
following along. And also, the reason I'm using markdown language for the steps is in VS code,
it has a preview option. So you can actually preview that markdown. And it renders it like
it would in a web page. So this is what we get, we get a directory called backend, we get a directory
called steps. And then we have a get ignore, we have a Docker compose file, which we need with
the firing up the project. We have a template ENV, readme file and the server PY. Don't worry
about server PY file. One of the containers that we're building in Docker is actually a Flask app.
And it allows us to just to fire up another application and make requests to the API.
The reason I'm using Flask is because it's, it's a lot easier to set up a Docker container using
Flask than it is Django. In this instance. So let's not worry about that too much. Let's go ahead
and open up module one steps and open up as a preview. I'm hoping that's going to look okay
on the screen. I'm going to close my terminal for now. There we go. So I'll say this now and not
throughout the course, each module has a start, a middle and an end, the start will show you what
your config, your directory configuration should look like, where your files are, how they're
configured. When I watched previous courses to this years and years and years ago, I found that
I'll be following along and I'll be saving files in the wrong directories and wrong, the directory
to be called something slightly different. I've tried to be as thorough as possible. This is what
your directory should look like at this present moment in time. And at the end of the file, right
at the bottom here, this is what it should look like at the end of the module. Hopefully that's
going to be helpful for you. And the middle part of the module is the instructions and the walk,
the step by steps that I'll be walking along with you. So look, we've got a backend directory,
a steps directory and a few files. So we're good to go. If you're ever in doubt and you've
cloned this down from Git and you can change and pull down the code from the module branch as it
went, and that should reconfigure things for you. Okay, steps, commands. You should now have a
directorial DRF course in your development directory. This will be known as your root
directory. In this module, we will be starting our project. To do this, we need to create a virtual
environment. Now, this is Dockerized. We don't necessarily need the virtual environment when
we've got the Dockerized project. However, I do reference some bits and pieces in the rest
framework directory that we're installing. Now that's all installed in Docker, but it's handy
to have the virtual environment in the project also so I can open up those files. So just bear
with me. So first thing you want to do, you want to invoke this command, this Python command,
and we'll open up our terminal. Make sure you're in the root directory and we're creating a virtual
environment and we're calling it venv. I'm on a Windows machine, so to fire up that virtual
environment, I use this command here. Okay, and how do I know it's running? I've got venv
in brackets there. Can you see that? Now we can go ahead and we can install all the dependencies
of the project. I want this to be more about Django rest framework, rather than Python and
pip and Django. So I've already created a requirements file, which is in backend, which
is here. It looks like this. Now when we run the following command, it will cycle through
these and install them into our virtual environment. Okay. So go back to the module,
back to the module, and we will take this command, pip install, and we'll point it
towards the requirements file in backend and it cycles through and it'll install everything.
You can see one of the things we're installing is Django rest framework,
Django rest framework, JSON API, and Django filters. They're all working together in this project.
We also got Python dot env. This allows us to identify environment variables in a file
in the project. And that way we can have secrets and API keys and things like that in here.
Okay. And this is the, this is the file that we'll be using for that. Okay.
This that will command at the bottom here, the bit in yellow is saying, uh-oh, you need to
upgrade pip. You can do that. It's not necessary really, but let's go ahead and do that.
Place that and that should go ahead and then that'll update pip and you won't see that
problem anymore. Good. Right. Go back to module one. It's a lot easier when I'm, um, not mirroring
my screen because my text is far bigger. So I don't get to see as much. So, uh, we've installed
everything right now. We've installed Django. That's the most important one actually in this
instance. Um, Django 4.1.3. Okay. So that's the version of Django that we've got installed by
installing it. We now have access to the Django commands and Django admin commands. One of those
commands we're going to use is start project. Okay. So we use Django admin, start project.
I don't want to dwell too much on this because it's not a Django course. It's a Django REST
framework course. Um, there we go. What we're doing, we're starting a project and we're dumping
it in backend. We should now see this DRF course on the left hand side here. Good secrets. We want
to copy the template that comes with the course and we want to call it dot ENV. So we now have
this file here and this will be picked up in the Django project. So it's looking for a secret key.
It's looking for allowed hosts. Okay. But it's already pre-configured. You don't want to worry
too much about that. And that, when I say module one and two is all about setup, that really is.
Okay. So our configuration in module one, let's close this, should now look like this. We've got
backend. We've got a new DRF course, which is here. See that we've got an init file. We've got ASCII,
WSGI URLs and settings. Okay. That comes straight out of the box when you set up a Django project.
We've got a new directory called virtual ENV or VENV. If I open that up, it's got include,
lib and scripts. In lib, we'll have site packages. And if you look in here, this is everything that
we just installed. We've installed Django REST framework, loads of other stuff, but Django REST
framework is really the heart of this course. Okay. If you go in here, we've got files such as
serializers. So we'll be importing this in some of the projects. Some of these classes and methods
will be calling quite a lot in this course. So we'll become familiar with this setup
up soon enough. Okay. But that is the end of module one. What we'll do is we will have a
quick sneak peek here of module two. So we'll close this. We're going to steps module two.
And the next module we will be, we'll be setting up a new app called core and we'll be added some
bits and pieces to the settings file. Okay. So that's module one. See you in the next module.
Okay. This is module two. What we're going to be doing is having a look at this module two,
which is in the steps directory. We'll open it up and we'll open it as a preview. And as I said,
in the last module, these files are broken down as a top middle and the bottom, the top, the bottom,
show you the configuration, start and finish. And a bit in the middle is all about following steps
that we can follow along together. I know that this is correct because I just completed it in
module one. Just make, make sure that your configuration is where it looks or what it looks
like on the screen before moving on. And if not, just pull down from get. Okay. So Django makes
easier to build better web apps more quickly with this code. That's why I love Django so much. Right.
So in this module, we'll be creating a Django app. A Django app is a Python package that is
specifically intended for use in Django projects. An application may use common
Django conventions and it's normally all bundled up. Right. So we're going to create two apps in
this project. One of them is going to be called core. The other one will be called e-commerce.
We won't bother ourselves with e-commerce just yet. Let's focus on core. So this app will hold
logic around core functions of the app. In this case, it's going to be a contact us model,
serializer and view. So a user can buy some information at us at an end point. We'll take
the information, we'll save it into the database. In this instance, it will be a username, an email,
so a username, a first and the last name, an email and a message. And we'll store that in
the database, which is quite helpful stuff. Okay. What we want is python manage.py start app core.
That is the command we're going to be using, but you need to be in the backend directory. It won't
work in DRF course because we're calling the manage.py file, which is in here. Okay. So CD
backend, and then we'll add that command here. And it should start a new app called core. You see
that we now have access to it. However, we do need to tell Django that that core is active. So we need
to change some bits in the settings file. So let's take this code. I don't want to glance too much
over the steps, but I don't also don't want to read it straight from the screen. So we need to
change some settings. Okay. So there's kind of three or four parts. We need to change. First
thing we need to do is change the imports at the top of the screen so that we can actually access
ENV environment variables. We're using python.env for that. And we just need to invoke instantiate
it. So we have access to it. So if we open up Django, so DRF course, and then go to settings.py.
This settings file has been constructed straight from Django. Okay. So it's got no changes in there
at all. You want to change this first line or line 13 and everything about it and just paste in what
I've just copied from the module. We've still got the path except now we're importing.env.
We're importing operating system, which is a Python package. And now we're instantiating.env
with load.env. Okay. It's not DRF stuff, but it just is really helpful so that we can store
information outside of the settings. Next thing we want to do, we want to change secret key,
debugging allowed hosts. So go back in steps, pick this up and drop it over this here. And what
that's now doing is rather than looking at the secret key that comes straight out of the box,
it's looking at the secret key in the ENV file, debug out of the ENV file and the allowed hosts
out of ENV, which are these here. Okay. Great stuff. You're all with me. Next, we need to tell
Django that we want to use the core app that we've just created, but also we want to use
Django extensions, which is a great package that you can install into a project. We're going to be
using Django filters and REST framework. REST framework and Django filters work together.
REST framework gives us access to all of the view sets, the serializers, the routers and things
like that. So essentially you add an installed app so we can actually use Django REST framework in
the project. So we want to copy this and we'll drop that directly in installed apps. Okay.
Django extensions, again, it's not DRF, but you have a load of module abstracts
and that we can just use in our models in the project to allow us to have loads of
fields without having to code it up and it just speeds things up. Good. Next, we need to add some
specific Django REST framework variables. Go to the bottom of the settings file. So pick it up
from the steps file and drop it in here. Okay. So what are we creating here? We're creating a
variable called REST framework. So Django REST framework is looking for this variable in the
settings file. Okay. This is taken straight from Django REST framework.org and it's kind of a basic
setup. It's a load of key value pairs in a dictionary and it just adds some bespoke settings
to the instance of Django REST framework that we're playing with. One project might want token
authentication, another one might want pagination, things like that. Okay. So you can see we've got
exception handlers, we've got default pass classes, renderer classes. What else have we got? We've
got test request default format. So when we write some tests later, this is the default format of
the data that is being sent. Okay. And we'll add to this throughout the course. So we will be doing
some token authentication in this course. You'd be pleased to know. I think that's in module five.
And yeah. Okay. They are the settings. URLs. Okay. So normally when you're working with a
Django project, you do things in a certain order. So you install the packages, change your settings,
add the URLs to the URL conf because some of the packages require that. And then you go about and
you create apps, models, forms, views, URLs. Okay. In that kind of order. So we'll go through that,
but this is the URL conf. What I'm going to do here, so we're going to add this to URLs
straight out of the box. It wires up admin. We're not going to change that because it's handy to
have access to the built-in admin page in this course. So we'll keep it as it is, but instead
what we're now brought in is two things. So we've got REST framework, import routers.
Think of a router in Django REST framework as a way of directing routing traffic to your API,
to the correct view. Okay. That's what we're doing there. So when a request comes into an endpoint
that we specify, the router will help to direct that towards the view. It works well with the
URL patterns that Django uses. Okay. So that's why we're bringing this in here. You can write
a bespoke router, but the default route will, for instance, if we're doing a retrieve call in a
view set, it will already know to look for the primary key. Okay. So you can have a bespoke
router that will look for type and key, but you need to write that. We're not doing that in this
course, but that is where you would handle that kind of logic. Okay. Migrations. Lastly, we now
need to migrate everything to a database. Now we are using the straight out of the box database.
We haven't got a post-rescue database or anything in this course. So by running migrate,
make migrations and migrate, we'll be creating a database file essentially, and that will appear
in the project. So let's go ahead and use these two commands. Look at my terminal. You see that?
We're in the correct directory backend, and we click migrate. That's exactly what we're expecting
to see. In Django, in the installed apps, there's certain things here like auth and content types
and sessions that have database tables. Now we will be using auth especially. We need those tables
in our database. So we run those migrations and migrate those tables into this. This is our
temporary database. This is not a production ready database or anything like that, but this is what
we'll be using. So we've just done that and we can now run a local server. So we'll do that quickly.
We are going to use Docker in another module, but right now let's just fire up the server. Can you
see that? And that will say everything's looking good. And if we open up my browser and go to 127,
and we'll just paste it in there. Oh, that's not what I wanted to apologize. One second.
I think localhost should work. Yeah, there we go. It does work. So this is exactly what we want to
see at this point. It means we have configured things exactly where we need them to be to see
the web API in our browser. You can see that we've got no endpoints at all, but the built-in
homepage, if you like, is just a basic get request. And that's why you're looking at this page.
Okay. So in the next module, we will start building out our core app. So we'll build some models,
serializer, some views and routers so that we can actually make a call to an endpoint and
make it all work. Good. Where are we? So that is module two. Thank you very much. I'll see you in
module three. Okay. Module three. Let's begin. I will just close down some of the bits from the
last module. Let's go to steps, module three, and we're going to preview. Good. So module one and
two was all about setup and config. Okay. Arguably you could skip to this point if you're really good
at Django and you know what you're doing, you can start here. It's a basic setup. So start and end.
So the start configuration should look something like this, the directory configuration. We've got
a core app in backend, which is good. We've got that straight out of the box stuff. Nothing fancy
pants in there. Got a Docker file. Don't worry about that. Got DRF, got a DBSQL Lite file,
which we have. We've got it here. That's a new file. And then we've got everything else that we
had. So we're all good to go. We don't need to change anything, but if you've lost track a little
bit, you can pull down from module three from GitHub. Good to go. Right. In the last module,
we wired up to one new app, should I say as a typo. What we now need to do is we need to create
a contact us endpoint so a user can send their name, email, a message to our backend. What we
need is a module. This is a Django convention. So we create a module which translates to an SQL
table with fields. Okay. Okay. We need a router to direct traffic to the endpoint, to a view,
and then we need a serializer to serialize data. So a serializer is similar to a Django form.
So it does a lot of the heavy lifting. So a serializer is kind of a piece of code that
sits between a request coming in and the backend. Now it serializes the say JSON data into Python
data types and then back again. So it receives information, alters that information into
something that Python can read, validates it, does stuff in the background, and then it spits
it back to the user. That's what a serializer is doing. Very similar to a form, right? So
that's what we need to write. And then we have a view. The view handles all of the logic. This
will be a view set or a API view. An API view is very similar to a normal Django class-based view.
But with Django RIS framework, they have some other views that we can use as well, like API
view, view sets, and some built-in mixings that we can use as well. Okay. So let's start with
models. Remember we do models first. So pick up the code that you can see on the screen here.
Copy it, go into core, go into models, Ctrl A, Ctrl V. Okay. And then save. It will have a dodgy
import. Don't worry about that. We'll cover that off in a second. But essentially we're importing
models from Django. And we've got some extensions. So remember Django extensions give us some
abstract models that we can use. A timestamp model gives us a couple of fields like created.
An activator model will give us a status field and an activated date and a deactivated date.
And a deactivated date. And also we'll have a title description model. That gives us a character
field or two character fields, text field. And the reason I'm adding those is because
the first name and the message will be a character field and a text field.
All we need to do is just direct the serializer to the correct field. And that's why I wanted
to add it into the course. And then we've got a model called contact. We're inheriting some
bits and pieces here, including an abstract called model. Each of the tables in this course will have
a UUID as an ID field. We'll create that in a second. Got meta class, and then we're adding
an email field. So this is just the models.email field. All right. So this is, this is what we'll
be adding to the serializer also. And then we've got to done the string method here, which is a
string representation of the model. Again, don't need to do a deep dive on this. This is a Django
Django model. And this is what the database will have in it. Let's construct that abstract.
So abstract models, you will notice that we're importing an abstract model. I've already spoken
about that. We're going to have a ID field in each of our models with a UUID field. So copy this here
in backend, we want a new directory. So we'll call this utils. Within that, we want a new file
called thunderinit.py. And then another file in there called model abstracts.py and dump all of
that code in there. Paste. Okay. Bringing in UUID from a Python, that's a built-in Python package,
and then models. And all we're doing here is we're creating this class called model. It has an ID
field, which is a primary key. Okay. So we, we're using that primary key when we're making calls to
the API. And then in the class meta, we call it, we're saying abstract equals true, which means
we can then inherit that in our, in our contact. Again, let's not dwell on that too much. Okay.
Good. Serialize this. Remember serializer is some code that sits between the user request
and the backend and back again. So it handles the serialization of information data. Okay.
So we need to create a file in our project called serializers.py in core new file.
Okay. And then in there paste in this code, what are we doing? We are importing our model that we
just created for it's relative. That's what is this dot is here. And we're bringing in serializers.
So let me touch on this quickly. So when from rest framework, import serializers, what are we doing?
We are importing from our virtual environment. In this case, we're looking at a virtual environment
here. We're looking for rest framework and then we're looking for filing here called serializers.
Now by importing that we now have access to all of this. Okay. So in here we have the base
serializer, which will be abstract. Let's minimize some of this. So when we, when we create serializer
and we inherit serializers dot serializer, it's this class that we'll be using. Okay.
So you can see here we've got a default error message, we've got fields. So it's doing a lot
of hard work there. Another thing we've got is a model serializer. So a model serializer is just
a regular serializer, except that a set of default fields are automatically populated. So it links to
a model. It's model serializer. Okay. So serializer field mapping. So this is the logic where if you've
got a serializer field, it maps it to a model field. But this is the reason I'm showing you this is
this is what we're, we're importing. So a lot of courses you see online, it won't really do a deep
dive on this sort of thing. You know, this import serializers from serializers. What does that mean?
What are we actually using? So I'm just showing you that this is what we're doing. Okay. So when
we create a serializer, we're inheriting from these classes. So we have access to all of the
methods and functionality within good. And then yeah, from framework dot fields, we're accessing
child film and email field. Okay. They're the two fields that we're playing around with. Okay. So
let's create a contact serializer. We're inheriting model serializer. Remember this does the mapping
to the fields. We have a name message and email field, very similar to Django forms. Okay. So you
add a variable and then you say what field type is what widget you're going to use. This is very,
very similar except in this name. If you remember, we're using a Django extensions field called
title description. Now that gives us a field called title, but in the serializer, we want to call it
name. So what we do is we point this towards the title field. Okay. That's why we've got source
equals. That's what that keyword is doing. And we're saying required through. So we're expecting
that information to come through from the client. If we don't, it will get a 404 response. Same
again for message. We're pointing it to description and email where we know there's an email field,
right? So we've got an email field called email in the model. We have a class meta and in a
direct it to the model that we're looking for. And then the fields that we want. That's it. That's
all we need for the serializer. Okay. We're linking the serializer to a model that we have.
All we now need to do is wire up some views, save, but talking of views, let's take this code,
copy, go into views in core, paste that in and we'll save that. Okay. So, um, from Jason,
which is a Python package, bring in a Jason decoder error. Um, we're bringing in a Jason
response from a Django package. Then from dot serializers, which we just created,
we're bringing in a serializer and a few bits and pieces from rest frameworks. We've got parsers.
This allows us to handle the parsing of the Jason that we're going to be receiving from the
client. And we've got views. So there's a whole bunch of different views that we can handle.
Let's have a look. You know, the views here, we're using an API view in this instance. Now,
an API view is very similar to a Django class based view. And in a way you can have a get
method, a post method, so on and so forth. So it'd really, really helpful if you've been working
with Django for a long time. It's a good, nice, easy transition to use API views, but you have
other bits and pieces in here as well that you can also use. Good. And then you've got status.
So status gives us access to a whole bunch of predefined statuses that are in, um, rest framework.
So HTTP, uh, 200 equals 200. And we use that in the responses. We feed back to the client.
Okay. So contact API view, parsing through views, the API view, which is
Was it this? No, sorry, got too much open. Is this it? This is what we're parsing through.
Okay. So we've got a deep, uh, we've got schema, got as view. Okay. So
remember it's like a class based view. And if you're going to render that to a webpage in
Django, you would use a dot as view at the end of it. If we have a function based view, you don't
need to do that. Um, we've got some other methods here that we've got. We won't go in, it's not a
deep, deep dive. This is a very sort of top level. Um, so we've got a get serializer context method.
And we've got a get serializer method. Um, and at the top here in an API view, you need to put the
serializer class. So the serializer class in this instance is a contact serializer. So we'll be using
these two methods here to handle the getting off that serializer in an API view. So we now have
access to that serializer. And anyway, we've then got, what's the most important part of this view
is the post request. So what we're doing here is we are expecting some Jason to be sent in from a
client. First thing we want to do is to pass that Jason using a, the parser that's built into the
Django REST framework. Um, we then use this, we send that data through to the serializer to handle
the, um, serialization of information. Remember pointing it to the right fields.
And if the information that's coming in is valid, i.e. there was a name, a message and an email,
and the email is an email type, um, data type, and it'll be valid, same as a form, no different.
Then what you do is you save the serializer like you would a Django form, and it saves that
information to the database. What you then do is you send a response back to the front end,
which is the data from the serializer. Send information in, serializer takes the information,
checks it, validates it, saves it to the database, sends the information back.
Okay. That's what we're doing in this post method. If it's not, if there's an error,
then we spit back a 400 bad request. We know in, it's not in views, we know in status,
where is it there, that 400 is bad request and it will spit back a 400. Okay.
And then if the encoding of the, if it doesn't come in as a proper JSON, then the decoding will
fail and we'll send back a status 400 with an error message as well. Okay. So we're handling
the information coming in, in this post request via review, same as you would in a view in Django.
Okay. But now what we need is a router to route the traffic from the endpoint to the view.
So what we need is
in previous courses, I would have put a URLs or router file in here, but we're just using it from
the DRF course, so the URL conf file. So, okay. We've just added that. So we've imported what's
different. We've imported the cause views that we just created and we've added a new path to
URL patterns. Now this is a, this is a API view. Again, like a class-based view, that's why we've
got the as view at the end. Endpoint is contact and it's core views, contact view. So it's very
similar to a URL pattern that we'd normally use in Django anyway. So this is why it's so easy to
kind of get your head around if you're good at Django. And that's the, that's the, that's the
router. I think, no. What do we do? When we create models in Django, we register them so we can access
them in a built-in admin page. So if you go into admin.py and save this code, it'll give us, it
will register contact to the admin page and give us access to any instance that is saved to the
database. Last thing we want to do is migrate the changes that we've got it in the database.
Don't want that. Don't want that one. Let's go to CD backend. Remember you need to be in backend to
invoke the manage.py file. No more Django filters. Okay. No more. You know, the reason that's done
that is because we have not got a virtual environment. You see that in the bottom left,
there's no open bracket ENV. So what I need to do is the ENV backslash scripts, backslash activate
.bat because I'm on a Windows machine, CD back in the backend and then use those same pieces of
code again. There we go. Good. We now have, you see we've migrated contact and we might, so we
create a migration file and we've migrated it to the database. So by running those commands,
we've created this file here and you can see we're creating a model called contact with all of these
fields. So we've got ID, which is a UUID field, created modified title description. So with one
line of coding models here, because we're inheriting all of this, it actually creates a whole bunch of
other fields, which is it. And then we've migrated it to the database. Good. Now we are in a position
to make a call to the data and make a call to the API. So what we'll do is we will deactivate,
just deactivate your virtual environment when you're doing this. We will CD that one. So we're
going to DRF course. And now what we want to do is we want to fire up Docker. So you go Docker
compose up dash D dash dash build. What that would do, that will call this file here. And whilst
that's just doing what it needs to do, I'll just show you what's in there. We're creating two
containers. Okay. So the API, this is the Django app and another app, which is a Flask app, which
is a really, really small lightweight container that has Curl HTTPI installed, which will allow
us to make a HTTPI request to the API. HTTPI, sorry, HTTPI is very similar to Curl, except
the response you get is really, really easy on the eye. And it's much, it's just better. I find it
better than just a normal co-request. Now Docker should be running. Happy days. Look at the app.
Sorry, that's a bit small. There we go. This is the app. So this is Flask. And then I'll be doing
a lot of zooming. And then we've got the API. There we go, which is very similar to what you'd
be seeing if this was running is in your local terminal. Okay. So that's working perfectly well.
I'm really happy with that. So we're going to app and open up the CLI, which is the equivalent is
a command line interface. It's the same as your terminal. It's just, we have access to HTTPI.
So what I'll do, I'll go back into module three and I will, where is it? Where is it? Where is it?
Where is it? We will make this call. So what is this? HTTPI, that is the, I say you invoke a call
using HTTPI, similar to curl. We give it the endpoint. In this case, API is the name of the
host for the Django project. Before it had been local host or 127.0.0. The 8,000 is the port.
No different if it was local host 8,000. It's just when you're in Docker in this course,
you'll be using API. We pass through name, message, and email. They're the three fields.
Copy this back in Docker, paste it there, and then press enter. And you can see that it's,
I can't, I'm zoomed in, so I haven't got access. But you can see the JSON at the bottom there.
That is the response we're getting from the API. So it's saying that it's actually created
an entry in our database with an ID of 881896. So that tells me it's worked. Now I can
demonstrate that it's worked by logging into the admin page, but I won't in this module.
Perfect. That is exactly where I want it to be at the end of this module.
So we've got a new configuration of what a directory should look like on the left hand
side here, but we're not going to look at that. So don't worry, but please double check before
you move on to the next module. So thank you very much. And I'll see you in module four.
Okay. Module four. Let's, sorry, I'm recording this as one here. I'm not editing at all. So
all of these screens are open because they were open a second ago. So module four, let me just
tidy things up in my screen. Right. There we go. Module four, go into preview.
This is what it should look like. Pause, have a check. I'm not going to spend too long on that,
on that. Clone down if you need to make sure your directory setup is the same as what it is on my
screen. So in the last module, we built a contact endpoint. Now we want to do some tests. Okay.
A, an app without tests is broken by design. Okay. So that's on the Django website, but it's very
much true. If you don't have tests in your app, then you know, you're not going anywhere with it.
So what we'll do, we'll pick up all of these test cases that are pre-written
and I'll copy them and I'll go into backend core, open up the test.py file and drop them in.
So if you're used to writing Django tests, what you'd normally do is you'd use,
you'd write some unit tests and you'd test different methods and views and things like that.
Well, in REST framework, you have something called an API client. Well, that constructs a client
similar to HTTP or the container in Docker to make a call to the backend. This is just a built-in
REST framework API client allows us to make post, put, get, delete requests.
So that's what we're bringing in there. We've also got API test case. Okay. So we're bringing in those,
the contact test case inherits from API test case. And it's very similar to the Django test cases.
You need a setup method, which constructs things in the test database, and then you can make calls
against them. Okay. And then again, we're bringing in status like we did in the view. So we're going
to do assert equals against some of these tests that we're constructing. And we're expecting
200s, 400s, 404s, and things like that. So if you use the Django, these are just pretty normal
Django tests, but because we're using REST API or Django REST framework API test cases, it will
spend a little bit of time going through this, no more than a few minutes. So there's a setup method.
We're calling self.client, the API client. Okay. So we can access the API client by self.client
in the methods themselves or in the test cases. We create a dictionary here, Python dictionary
called self.data, and we add a name, message, and an email field. This is what we're expecting
from the contact endpoint. And then a URL, which is self.url equals contact. Okay. So let me
minimize some of these. Now it's important to note that we can call these when we run
a Python manage.py test, or that's already built into the Docker instance. So when we fire up
Docker, it automatically finds these tests and it runs them. So we've got what? Eight test cases
here. So we test the endpoint. We test the contact endpoint without a name. We test the contact where
name equals blank. And then we do similar to the message. And we do similar to email, except with
the email, what we also then do is we do send an email, but we send a data type that isn't an email.
So it'd be like a string without an at symbol in it. So that's quite thorough test cases for just
single endpoints. We've got eight tests. The first one is we, sorry, that's not the first one.
The first one is we get the data from self.data. The response is self.client. So this is the same
as requests actually, say response equal requests.post, very similar to that. In this case,
it's request.client.post. You pass through the URL and then you pass through the data, which is in
this case, what we're expecting. I would expect HTTP 200 OK, which is a 200 response. I would
also expect that the database has one entry in it. And I'd also expect that that database
entry title is Billy Smith, because that is what's in here. OK, next, I won't go for each of these
because I'm sure you understand testing. What I do, I take the data and I use the dictionary
method pop to remove name. So now we've got a dictionary without a key value name. Post it,
I expect it to say 400 because we're expecting name and hasn't got one. Again, rather than popping
it completely, I remove name and just add a blank string instead and expecting 400. So these last
seven test cases, I'm expecting 400s. OK, so that's testing. Go back in a module. What we
can then do is we can use this command, Python manage.py in Docker. But this time we want to go
into the API container. That's the app container. I apologize. Go back in here, go into CLI. Changes
I make locally will work in Docker because I'm using something called volumes. So persists data.
So essentially what happens outside of Docker in my project will also be in the Docker container.
So those test cases will now be there. Should be.
There we go. So it's run eight tests. We've created eight tests. They're all OK. So every time we're
looking for 200 bang on every time a 400. Perfect. So now what we can do is we've already done this.
We've already done this. As in we've sent the test case. We sent it, did this in the last module.
We don't need to do it again. OK, but we can check the database. So if we use Python manage.py shell,
in here, and just zoom, it just invokes a Django shell or Python interpreter, the Django. Same as
what you'd see locally. Now, what we can do here is we can say from core dot models. Import. Import
contacts. So we can say C equals contact dot objects dot last and then C. OK, and Bobby
Stearman. OK, that was the call we made in module two. Module three, sorry. OK, can you see that?
It's probably quite small. I do apologize. It's just you can't change the font size in Docker yet.
OK, so there we have it. That worked. And that's it. That's module four. Your directory
configuration should look like this on the screen. If it's not, pause, check, go back, make sure it
does before we move on to the next module. I'll see you in module five. OK, module five.
What have we got here? We've got back end. We've got steps. That's everything closed down. So we're
picking up exactly where we left off in module four. So we're going to steps and module five.
We'll open up as preview. We're halfway through the course now. So it's probably a good time for me
to say, look, if you like this content, please visit DidCoding's YouTube channel and subscribe
and click the bell because you like other content that I add. And also drop a like on this actual
video on FreeCodeCamp and comment as well, because I do get to see them. It's always good to have
feedback. So start and end of these step by steps. Just make sure the configuration on your local
machine matches what's on here. If not, clone it down. We've built our core app. We now need to
build an e-commerce app. The e-commerce app will be used to, it'll have two endpoints. It'll have an
items endpoint and an order endpoint. So we want users to be able to call an endpoint and retrieve
all the items that we've got in our shop. Okay. And also call it same endpoint and pass through
a primary key to identify a single item. And then if they want to purchase it, they place an order.
So there'll be an order endpoint for that particular item. So on top of that, we want to
do some validation. So we want to make sure that the item has stock. We want to also make sure
that only users that are authenticated can access these endpoints. So there's a few little bits
we're going to be looking at over the next four modules. We're going to add token authentication
to our app. We're going to build out some models, some new serializers. We're going to add some
validation to the serializers and see where it leads us. Great stuff. Right. So let's use this
command here in backend. If I close them down again, I will close the terminal down completely
because I'm using Docker now. Remember you can fire up Docker with Docker dash compose up dash D
dash dash build. No, yeah, that's right. And now fire up this app in Docker. And when you're in
there, you can then use these Python commands in the API. So we'll quit the shell and we're done
for that in here. Yes, we will in the API. And this is me making these calls in Docker. However,
you will see them appear in my local machine. And the reason you'll see them on my local machine
is because the data persists and we're using volumes. So e-commerce is now here. We need to
change the rest framework variable in settings. The reason being is because we are adding token
authentication. What we've done here is we've had, we've added a default, default authentication
class called authentication dot token authentication. So anywhere where we add a permissions class
in a view will enforce authentication. So you won't be able to access that view unless you
pass through a valid token. Okay, so that's the first step. In fact, if we do DRF token authentication,
this page here will walk you through all of the steps, but I'm doing that
for you. So just follow the modules. So I've added that we now need to add a new app into our
installed apps. So back in the settings, go into our installed apps, save over. You can see now
that we've got authentication added there. Okay. That stands to reason that we'll probably be adding
some URLs and making migrations because we're getting new tables in the database. Okay.
So let's go back to our URL conf. And you can see now we've got a new endpoint and we've got a new,
oh, we do apologize. So we're importing from Django REST framework and we've got a new endpoint.
Save that. So this means now we've got an endpoint in our project where when a user visits that
endpoint and passes through a username and a password, they will then receive back a token.
That token acts as an authentication token. So if we receive that then in the backend, we know
that that token links to a certain user. Okay. Keep tokens safe. So we've got a new endpoint,
keep tokens safe. Now we need to migrate those new tables that we've added in installed apps
to our database. So we go back in the Docker, paste those pieces of code in there
and zoom in. You can see now, can you see that? We've got auth token. We've got initial auto and
token proxy, which are the migration files for the tables that we're now having on the database.
Don't worry. We'll see them in the built-in admin table very, very soon.
What we also need is something called a signal. Now, if you're familiar with
Django, you'll know what these are. We want a way of creating a token every time a user is
created in the database. The way we do that is we use a signal. Now a single, a piece of code, which
in Django, we call a signal, something that receives a signal from a certain table
based on an action. Now that could be a pre-save or a post-save. So when a database has a new
instance saved in it, a signal is sent from the database and this receiver has an antenna and it
picks up that signal and says, ah, okay, I need to do something. And in this case, it will be create
a new token. That's what we're trying to do here. So we go into e-commerce. We have a new file called
signals.py. Sorry, I'm not following the modules. Sorry, the module five steps, step by step. I am
going step by step. I'm not reading straight from the screen. So you can see we've got a post-save
signal. So after something's saved, we get a signal. We have a receiver to receive said signal.
What table? The core user table. So when a user is added to the database, that's who sends the signal.
And what do we want to create? We want to create a new token, which is the new table we've created
in a database. And this is what the code all looks like. We now need to wire that into the app. So
when the app starts, the signal is active. It's looking for signals. And what we do in here is we
say def ready. So it's a ready method. Pass through self. What do we do? We want to import from
ecommerce.signals. Perfect. Now when ecommerce starts, signals will be active. That's what this
bit here is. What do we want to do now? We want to create our first user. We'll make it a super
user. So I want the super user, which is twofold. That will trigger that token. So we'll have a token
and it'll also give me access to the built-in admin page, which I'll show you in a second.
So I'll copy, paste that in there. Can you see? Don't necessarily need to see it, but there you go.
Enter and that will ask me for a username. Just Bobby. Don't worry about an email address.
Just a random password. There we go. User is created. I'd expect to see a token in the database.
So go in your browser. We will go to localhost forward slash admin, because that's the URL. Bobby
password. Perfect. I expect to see Bobby in the user table, because that's my super user.
If I look in tokens, there we go. It's created a token and this is the key. So this is my
authentication token. Perfect. You go back into modules. What we now need to do is we need to test
the end point. So I expect to, when I test this end point, I make this call using HTTP, HTTP in
the Docker, I would expect to receive something like this, which would be an endpoint response.
And it will say token. It will give me my new token. So what I'm going to do is take most of
this, but you need obviously use your own username and password. So I'll copy this
and I will go to the app container. Remember we're making a call from app to API,
go in a CLI, drop that in there. And I will say, well, username is Bobby password equals
presenter. Perfect. See that? So it starts in eight B eight eight.
We go back into the database, eight FB eight eight. Perfect. That's exactly what I wanted to see.
That's it. We've just added what we are module five, which is added token authentication to a
project. This is really good stuff. So now we can add that to our views. So if somebody's trying to
access information, they will only access information relative to that user. That's what
we're able to do. Not always the case. You might just want to have authentication on
certain views so that only authenticated or signed in users can access it. It's good if you imagine
you've got a mobile app, which, you know, is completely disconnected from the back end.
Okay. Same as a react or a view app. So where are we? That's it. That's module five. Thank you
very much for watching. I'll see you in module six. Okay, module six. Let's go ahead and begin.
Um, let's go ahead and begin. Like I said, I'm recording this in one fell swoop, so
please excuse the cluttered, uh, left hand side. So steps module six in preview.
We've built our core app, configured everything. We've got a generous framework working. We've
now got an e-commerce app with token authentication in this module. Just make sure your configuration,
by the way, is exactly where it needs to be on the left hand side. It should look like this.
It's not cloned down. What we're going to do now is we're going to go through the same process.
We went in the core app, build our models, build our serializers, build our views,
build our URLs in that order. Okay. So remember models relate to databases. So we need an item
and an order model. So a model to catch all the items in the database.
So go into backend e-commerce models, drop them in there. And I'm not going to spend too much time
going through this, but it's important you understand some of the methods. So we've got
an item model with some fields, right? We've got a stock and a price. So what stock we have in the
database and what the price is now prices in pence and pounds or cents and dollars, whatever the case
may be. It doesn't really matter. We've got a method to convert it into, remember if you're in
pounds and pence, if you divide pence by a hundred, you've got your pounds. You've got managed
stocks. We've got a method to decrease stock by a factor of whatever the order is. Okay. And we've
got another couple of methods here to place an order to check stocks. So when you place an order,
it checks the stock. If there's enough stock or the stock equals the order or is above the order,
then it calls managed stock. So that's one of the validation methods we'll be using in the serializer.
And then we've got an order model, which will relate to the user. So foreign key to the user
will be the item that's been ordered and the quantity. Okay. So then we'll have an endpoint
to view all of the user's orders. Okay. All of the items, retrieve a single item, retrieve a single
order, retrieve all of the orders. So, okay, that's all we're doing in the models. We now need a new
file called serializers.py. So I'm jumping forward. There we go. E-commerce serializer.py.
You now need to pick up all of this code, copy, go into e-commerce, drop it in there and save.
So bringing in the two models we've just created. And then for very similar to the core app,
we're bringing in serializers, bringing in status and exception. The reason I'm bringing in exceptions
is because I've got this class here, which is called a not enough stock exception. In a normal
app, you'd probably have a number file here called exceptions and you'd have a whole bunch of them.
So when you're validating, you can call, invoke, raise certain exceptions based on validation.
We're only doing one piece of validation. We're checking that the stock is high enough
or we've got adequate stock to cover the order that's coming in. So if when calling the method,
check stock, stock is too low, we will raise not enough stock, which is a 400 bad request.
The details say there is not enough stock and it'll be an invalid code. Okay. Model serializer,
item serializer, order serializer is another model serializer. So these serializers, again,
I spoke about this in module two, I believe there's a whole bunch of different serializers.
You don't need to use model serializers. Like I said, that points it to model fields
and it kind of does this, this clever model matching, sorry, field matching. You can use
other sorts of serializer. There's one called just serializer, in which case you need to specify
what those fields look like. Outside of this course, you might want to do a deeper dive on that,
but we're using models. It stands to reason that we can use a model serializer. So this item
serializer has got no fields. We're not adding any fields, class meta, model item, and we've got
title, stock and price. Okay. There are three fields that we have in the database. Order
serializer, however, we're using an item primary key related field. What we're doing there is
we are saying that the item field in order serializer, remember we're cleverly pointing
fields towards model fields. We're saying that that particular field, identify it by its primary key
is a foreign key link between the two tables. So we're identifying that link via a primary key.
I hope that makes sense. Same meta as above, but this time we've got a validate method.
That validate method will be called when we call, when we save the, sorry, when we call it is valid.
So the is valid method will call validate and it will check to make sure that all the information
is as expected. Now, in this case, what we're trying to do is yeah, check the fields, other
fields. Okay. Bang on. Perfect. After that, we then want to check the stock. Now, if the stock
is too low, it will be, we will raise this, not enough stock exception. So it will be not valid.
Does that make sense? That's why we've got this method in there. It's being called when we call
the is valid method in the serializer. Okay. Then create a few models, pop them in the admin file
here so we can access them in the built-in admin page. Don't need to go too further on that. And
we need to migrate those new tables to the database. So if we open up Docker again, open up the API
container, sorry, not the app one, API container, open up CLI, pop them in there, press enter.
There we go. We created an item table and an order table. We should be able to see those in here.
We update, happy days. We've got an items, we've got an order. Actually, let's go ahead and create
some items, shall we? Add an item. That's one. That's one. We'll have a stock of 10, price 300.
Save and add another. That's two. That's two. Stock of 20, price 500. That'll be five pounds,
right? Okay. We've now got items in the database. So when we do call the endpoint,
we should see something. That is it. That is the end of module six. So the next module we'll start
adding the views and the routers. The module after that will add some tests and we should have a
fully functioning app at the end of that. So thank you very much for watching. Make sure your
route directory is what it needs to look like before you move on to the next module. I'll see
you in module seven. Okay. Module seven. Here we are. So two more modules, including this one.
There we go. Module seven. Look at this in preview. Make sure your configuration on the
left-hand side matches this. If you don't, clone down. Okay. Our e-commerce app is picking up
speed. We've got our models. We've got a serializer. We now need to wire it into some views.
So we need to pick up all of this code and drop this into backend e-commerce views, paste.
What we're doing different to what we did in core, this we're bringing in is authenticated.
Remember we're wired in token authentication. So by bringing this in and adding this to our views,
that will invoke the authentication class that we have in our settings, which is token
authentication. We're expecting a token to be sent via the request in the header as
authorization or authentication. So we've got an items view. We've got some mix-ins here as well,
actually. So a good thing about this is a generic view set. Okay. So we've had an API view. We're
now using a generic view set. Generic view set has built-in methods such as retrieve.
What are they? Retrieve, list, create, update. I forget what they all are now. But by using the
generic view set and some mix-ins, you get very, very similar to the generic views in Django,
actually. A lot of the methods are all built-in. You don't need to do a lot of heavy lifting,
especially when we're working with model serializers. Okay. You can see a good example
of this. This is the item view. Okay. We've got no methods. We're just passing through permissions.
Telling it what a query set is. We're telling it what serialize to use. By using those mix-ins,
I've got a list endpoint, as in show all. And I've got a show and retrieve. So it's a get request
for a single item. Okay. So we pass through the UUID or the ID of an item. You're retrieving one.
Very powerful. Next, we've got an orders view set here. Similar, passing through everything. I can't
remember if, actually, that's probably a hangover. So we're using the list and retrieve to get single
orders. Okay. We're using this update one, which I don't think I'm actually using. We've probably
got access to that URL, because that's what we're doing here. The view set, the generic view set,
will give you access to methods, but it'll also construct those endpoints for you as well.
On a API view, you need to add the as view method when you're wiring up the URL router. But with a
generic view set, you do it slightly different. I'll show you in a second. Difference here is,
again, permissions class. We've got a create method here. So this is what we're going to be calling
when we create an order. Different to core is we're passing through to the serializer, the data.
To the serializer, the data. Okay. If the serializer is valid, so we're going to call that,
is there enough stock? If there is enough stock, we're not saving the serializer, because this is
a model serializer linked to an order. We're not creating... We have to place an order. We're
calling a place order method. So we're not necessarily just saving a serializer. We're
doing it slightly different. We're calling a method in a model. So we're getting the item,
specific item based on a PK, the primary key. And then we're calling the order place order method,
which will create that order in the database. And then we respond with the... We pass through
the new order that we've created to the order serializer and the data. So that's how we're
sending the data back to the user. Okay. That's the view. Very simple, right? We now need a router.
Go back in the models, doing all of this in URLConf. So we copy this, go into DRF course,
go into URLConf, and we're going to add some bits. Okay. What are we doing? We're bringing
in the views from e-commerce, and then we're wiring up these generic view sets different
to the API view. Okay. We're putting as view here, same as a class space view in Django,
very similar API view. These are different. These are generic view sets. So we're using RegEx.
So it's a regular expression URL. E-commerce view. So this is the view set itself. Next,
we haven't got as view at the end there. Base name is item and order. And then what we do,
we're registering those to the router. The URL patterns become the URLs from the router.
Remember, so although we're registering things to router, because we're using generic view sets
and a whole bunch of other stuff, that router has a whole bunch of URLs. So we'll have a retrieve
and a list and a get with a PK that are already built in just by registering this. So the URL
patterns becomes vast. And then what we do is we append these three URLs to the URL patterns,
and that becomes a whole bunch of URL patterns for the project. Okay.
That's that. That's module seven. We are good to go. The reason I've stopped there is because
we're going to be doing testing in module eight. It's the last piece. We'll be doing some unit
testing and then we'll be testing those endpoints. Okay. So that, just make sure that your configuration
is looking how mine does or looking at does in the modules and you'd be good to go.
Right. Thank you very much for watching module eight next. Perfect. Right. Module eight,
module eight and close some stuff. Open up module eight. Good. Before we start,
make sure your configuration is exactly the same. If not, cloned down from GitHub,
let's move on to the steps. So like in module four, when we done the testing for our core app,
let's do it again for e-commerce, except this is a little bit more complicated.
Doesn't need to be any more complicated. I won't go into a big deep dive because I've already
spoken about the API client and test cases. So we're creating a client is a callable very
much like the request package. So we're calling the API testing and adding it to a test database.
Inheriting the API test case here. So we have a setup method. We're creating some dummy information
similar to what I did in the admin page earlier, adding five items. We're creating a self items
variable here, which is all of the items in the database. We're creating a user. Well, we know
when we create a user, we're also creating a token. We're creating a couple of orders. Okay.
Against the first item. That way we can call the order at any point. Token. So creating a token,
we know that we've just created it. Yeah. So it's self token is for this user here.
And then the client is API client. And then difference here is that on self client,
we can call the credentials method and pass through the token. So we'll add a header to each and every
call. Remember we've got permissions class in these views. So if we don't have that, we can call
class in these views. So if we don't have this, we're going to hit a failure each time. So we're
passing through the token. So now it will be written. It will be token space. So it'll be,
it'll say authorization, and it will say a token space, and it will be the token key. Okay. And
that'd be in the head of every call. And then we have how many? What have we got here?
We've got a few, one, two, four, six, eight, 10, 10 ish, 10 test cases. So what we're doing,
we are checking out what's in the database. We're expecting five, if there is happy days,
we've got, we make a call to the item endpoint. Remember we've got a retrieve list or a list
method. I'll bring back every item. So I'm making a call to it. We're expecting status 200. That's
the first endpoint. Now we want to get each item. So what we're doing, we're going to cycle through
all of the items. Now we're going to make five calls to the endpoint. You can do this differently,
but this is just one way of doing it. So I'm calling the endpoint five times and I'm saying,
right, get the item with PK from the item from the database. So item.id. We're expecting a 200
because we know that they're there, right? So we're getting a response 200. Then we get,
then we get a little bit complicated. So test order is more than stock. So we're now calling
methods, right? So for items, so these are methods in the item database. So current stock
is, so we're getting the current stock and then we're saying I check stock. So we're passing
through. So make check that the order is more than stock. So we'd expect that to be false.
We go through, I'm not going to go through each of these, but I'm basically testing every outcome
for the endpoint. So have we got too much stock? We've not got enough stock. Does the stock equal
the order? What happens if we don't send an item ID, something along those lines? Okay. So just
going through, I mean, you can probably be a lot more thorough than this, but these are the tests
that we've got. Modulate. Okay. So we can now go in here, go into Docker. I'm in API, which is
correct. We've got that drop to manage.py testing that we're now 18 to 18 core 10 in e-commerce
and expecting. There we go. Okay. All the tests work. This is where you want to be.
Now let's go ahead and test some endpoints. I need module eight opened and this is how you'll
probably need to do it as well. So I'll open up modulate without it being in preview mode.
The reason being is because every place it says your name, I'm going to control H and change it to
the username of the person in the database. I know it's Bobby. Can you change it? Can you change
your password? Whenever you see your password, I'm going to change that to my password. So what
we're doing here, I'm just creating the HTTP endpoints, your token. Every time I see your
token, I'm going to change that to the token in the database, which is this one here, copy
and change all the lows. And then you've got UUID for item. So you can see here,
we're calling the item endpoint. So your UUID will be an ID that appears in the database.
So we go into items, change this one, copy, not change that one. Oh, sorry.
It's like, it's a little bit difficult when you're just doing a right. And then we get onto,
after that we get onto orders. So we won't look at those yet. Okay, cool. So we go back and preview.
I should now have those. Yeah, we do. Right. So spend some time going through these. So let's
test all the endpoints there. So call our endpoints. Here are the requests we can make
to our new endpoint. So we've got first, what I'll do, I'm going to keep going backwards and
forwards, but we go to the app container, going to CLI. What we'll do, we will drop this in there.
So we're calling the API auth to get a token. There we go. Token, it works. I'm going to zoom
in each time. I know it's small. I do apologize, but at least you've got instructions. You've got
the code. Next, we want to check and get all of the items. Remember, this is the domain. The
endpoint is item. That is a retrieve all. We're getting all items in the database, providing we
send through the token back into Docker, drop it in there. And I expect to see two items. We've
got two in the database. Now what happens if I remove the header with the authentication token?
There you go. Not authenticated. Perfect. That's exactly what we want to see. Next,
we want to retrieve one item that we have in the database.
There we go. Pass through the UID, and it gets a single retrieved one item. Well, so we got this,
got retrieve all orders. Yeah, we can look at that one. Back to Docker, retrieve all orders.
We've got two. We haven't got any orders in the database. Let's make an order, shall we? Your UID
authentication. This will place an order for item ID. Sorry, I'm moving around on this. I probably
should have looked right. If I change that, this will retrieve all orders. This will retrieve a
single item. This will place an order for an item. Let's place an order for an item, shall we?
Sorry, not handy when you're making a video. What is this doing? We're calling HTTP. We're
calling the order endpoint. We're passing through an authentication token. Then we create an adjacent
data type, and we send it through the ID of the item and a quantity. I know that we've got the
stock of one. Let's copy that. We'll drop that in here. That will create an order. If I do that
again and change the quantity to 1,000, I know we don't have a stock of 1,000. That should say
there is not enough stock. Remember, we're validating that. If there's not enough stock,
we're raising an exception. Brilliant. Now we can call the... I'm seeing the trouble with Docker.
You can't press up and get your previous. Let's check all orders, and then I won't keep you on
here any longer because you can do this in your own time. We should now see one order, right?
There we go. Brilliant. That is exactly what I wanted to see. Just zoom in.
Again, we added an order of one, remember, and retrieved it.
I also showed you... Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? There we go.
What I'll do, I'll create another order just quickly, and I'll create that with five.
I believe we've got enough stock. There is. We will then get all of our orders with this one here.
Copy, back in the Docker. Drop it in there. It should now have two. Perfect. That's exactly
what I wanted to see. That is it. That is the end of the course. Let's just recap quickly. What have
we done? We've gone through eight modules. The first two modules were all about getting the code,
configuring a Django project, essentially. Nice and easy stuff. We have then created a core app
with a contact endpoint, a normal model serializer, and we've just got a post request. We're using an
API view, which is similar to a Django class view. Brilliant. We've then invoked or added
token authentication to the project, created an e-commerce app with an item and an order endpoint
with permission classes. Only those that have got an authentication approval can view, retrieve,
create information. We have now created a very, very good, not production ready,
API, but it's a good API that you can use and hopefully refactor and use it in your own project.
Now, I'd just like to thank everyone for watching. If you like this content, then please visit Did
Coding and you'll see many more videos like this on my channel. Like this video on FreeCodeCamp
and add a comment because I do get to see those comments. Comments from previous courses on
FreeCodeCamp really has led to me building some other courses and tutorials. Just before I do
close the video out, I just would like to thank FreeCodeCamp one more time just for allowing me
to create this course and for them to post it on their channel. Keep up the good work,
keep that free content coming. Again, thank you very much and hopefully I'll be seeing you very,
very soon. Bye-bye.